c'est un clip qui a été réalisé par
mario and stare qui j'ai collaboré sur
sur cette chanson mais on a on a conçu
le clip ensemble et avec grégoire moss
aussi qui travaillent avec moi donc une
première chose voilà c'est un clip
entre nous on l'appelait 3e titre en
seniors faith 2020 dans dans ton visage
ou non dans ta face voilà on a essayé de
résumer un petit peu les choses on n'a
pas du tout la même vision du monde et
la même lecture que que monsieur
alexandre précédemment donc vous vous le
verrez dans le plu voilà on a essayé la
dans un premier volet d'exposer à quel
point nos dirigeants et la classe
dominante nous mener vers la catastrophe
et dans un second volet du clip on a
essayé de montrer que heureusement il y
avait déjà des gens qui qui se battaient
pour sauver ce qui peut encore l'être
voilà donc c'est à la fois une amp enflé
et en europe
[Musique]